[Music]
remember we were talking about mark hart
mark harley
oh yeah
lion were we talking about the gayline
yeah big gay lion
so um i have a couple things a couple
things i want to get into here real
quick so um
mark harley
this is uh he was in i guess the studio
in the producer's booth sitting next to
their version of frozen asian
and um
[Music]
oh they've got a gay producer too
yeah yeah
wait a minute what
was that middle part former gay producer
yeah i'm not a natural
mesomorph the way you guys are a couple
mesomorphs in history i'm an ectomorph
yeah i'm a mesomorphism okay um just
naturally i'm not an endomorph
you're built like an ant i built like
well i got my leg i got the legs of a
frog got a bit of a booty on me we're
doing all right there no you're built
like the wb frog okay
you got it
that was a good one brandon very current
reference that's probably true bring
that up gin just don't have
the natural hard for me to put on muscle
yeah mark you've got a year you got a
year yeah you can do whatever you want
to make uh-huh you can i'll i'll take
whatever you put it's brian's body right
there but is the is there objective
aesthetics do you just want to look at
that that's all we want okay that's all
we want i'm not you want me to take it
from here mark steroids
steroids they're trying to talk brian
into steroids we know your age no i know
that we know we have to say definitely
if there's anything brian callan needs
because he's a hothead as you know
um and i'm also one of these people
because there is this real myth that
like anybody that takes steroids becomes
angry that's not true that's not true at
all there's a lot of people that think
steroids that aren't what steroids do is
they amplify your worst characteristic
right if you're already a hot head yes
certain steroids will absolutely make
you a little angrier shorter fuse right
but if you're somebody like john cena
you know who's not one of those like
crazy angry personalities yeah you're
not not only who who not only doesn't
have an angry personality but just has
people catering to them right you're not
he could just get up and go oh hey man
can you run down and just get me some of
the breakfast from the lobby like just
some eggs
brian callan almost started an
international incident because he
thought bobby lee
uh was going after brendan's family
where they were trying to kidnap him
like it was taken
there's no national incident he's the
reason north korea is still testing
missiles no that's a good point protect
bobby lee are you telling me dennis
rodman didn't fix that i haven't kept up
with the news in a while no cause dennis
rodman couldn't get through to brian
kelly ah god damn it
train on this earth has he tried being a
bipolar stand-up comedian that's a
female because you'll get right in
you'll get right in has he tried doing
stand-up in a theater in a movie theater
he's going to come out
right i work out every day but that
nothing's going to look exactly the same
yeah depending on what side effects
you'd want to avoid um i don't want to
die and i don't know oh no you can take
so many steroids before you die
yeah mark i i'm sure i look at you and i
know that is true insane yeah like
people have this notion of like well i'd
like to i'd like to not have it impact
my longevity ultimately like okay well
there's still a lot you can take as long
as i like his face get a little bloated
just for my own sake also steroid wise
wouldn't it be worse like i'm sure it's
way less
uh adverse to start doing them later in
life if you just do a little bit
because isn't the whole thing with heart
problems and steroids like lifetimes of
doing it like well i mean
your whole life it's also the type of
steroids you're taking
depending on whether good or the bad on
your heart it's it's the type of you're
taking it's the amount also that you're
even if you're doing the ones that are
better for you it's still a lifetime of
it yeah of course start pumping heart
pumping heart pumping it just starts
growing because it's a muscle yeah i
mean yeah again like i said if you're
older i'm pretty sure like you're just
going to do a couple cycles just to look
good i mean look at twilight
those are bright i mean brian kellen's
50 so i would actually agree with like
if you look now we're going to take it
take it you know [ __ ] it at that point
go nuts
just [ __ ] do some trt or whatever but
take a needle a little boosterini in the
uh in the butt cheek but
i brought i bring this up because um
i don't know if you know this
but mark harley
he's a rapper
no he's not yeah
yeah he is what up everybody it's mark
we're out here today in brooklyn new
york i'm gonna be going up to complete
strangers start rapping singing doing a
bunch of random crap to get a rise out
of them and a little thing we like to
call you rapping about me
you ready this can i just say something
i'm ready
yes this already feels like a tim
robinson sketch
does it not absolutely does
absolutely i'm already uncomfortable all
right you ready here we go
you look at me uh
we are not the same
let me go on amazon and order you some
rogaine
[Music]
i bet you don't remember the day you met
your dream boat
you were dressed like joseph in the
amazing technicolor dreamcoat
it's okay so he's he's also a bad rapper
he i mean i just want all the things
he's bad at i'm very uncomfortable how
do you think how do you think
[ __ ] b-e-t felt
this is b-e-t yep uh not only that this
is 50 cent show
yep
a fitty scent
yeah this guy this guy was probably 50
cents like steroid dealer yeah
oh my god probably god damn it
ah you might be right [ __ ] it god damn
it holy [ __ ] you might be right that's
always been just [ __ ] jack jack to
the gills yeah
[Music]
don't get up just yet you need to stay
put i'll take you home girl don't you
know why i lay good
[Music]
that's funny man bro this is a guy who's
tried everything like he's throwing he's
thrown every in his entire life he's
thrown everything against the girls
he's probably trying to stop
comedy
oh yeah but look listen they don't just
hand out san francisco comedy college
degrees to nobody okay no you're right
you have to pay three thousand dollars
that's right but here's the thing
before the steroids
i really like eminem's wrap on that yeah
it's like oh
there they go packing stadiums the shady
spits
they go macadamia they go so ballistic
bar you can make them look like bozos
he's wondering if he should spit this
slope [ __ ] no go for broken stop this
run
dude this guy
bro you're hey mark i know you're
watching this because i was talking
about you has more views than you're
showing your little you know what you
know mark this is really bad bro this is
real bad bro you know what mark reminds
me of
um
50 cent steroid the dealer
he's that really
he's that guy that's like just really
good looking and he's dating a female
friend of yours yeah and he's absolutely
useless but she just can't stop telling
like she he's the boyfriend that she has
to keep reminding us how great he is
okay look just say just say really just
say eric fernandez it's fine i mean
honestly just say the guy's name all
right oh shut up eric's not useless um
but this guy he's the guy that like
like he works at like an amazon
warehouse but he's jacked and
good-looking yeah but he's tried
modeling and failed and he's tried sound
cloud rapping and failed he was trying
acting and failed and then it's like you
always talk to your friend and go like
why are you still with this guy she's
like no he's really great he's like the
funniest guy ever and you and your
friends are all just like he's never
made me laugh once
i don't know what you see in this guy
and he realizes it's just because he's
jacked yeah you got you guys got a rent
a center credit card together
a joint rental center car
co-sign for an aaron's [ __ ]
in store buy here pay here credit yeah
no but wrap it above like this since the
last time that he overdosed they've been
waiting patiently for pinocchio to poke
his nose back into the game and they're
not rapping them but be the same as
people bashing the right hoodie so is it
establishing the name
so it's a big bone thugs fan or
something when he was younger he he's
had like
you know every chance in the world
yes okay you know what also yes
i've been posting the clips of his of
the of when we talk about them on the
clip channel because i think they're
funny
and i've been getting a lot of comments
from like burner accounts like you know
like accounts that are just freshly made
that are like you guys are the
definition of haters this mark harley
guy i'm like oh god stop bro please
don't tell me you're like please don't
tell me mark you don't you don't have a
listen you don't have a mark harley army
coming for us all right i stop it i
guess not i guess and by the way mark
good call girl on that beard bro trust
me i know it was a very good call trust
me i know kind of you kind of just look
like a jacked trevor moore
without the beard
[Laughter]
yeah the the chad is calling him gaber
tooth gaber tooth gabriel
i like gabriel gabriel tooth huh we got
a new one for you mark there you go mark
add that to your list of nicknames buddy
gabertooth
because it's like saber tubes but you're
a homosexual
you'll be you should like take steroids
b
bro somebody i was uh i gotta give a
shout out to the fighter and the kid
subreddit who by the way do not like us
either but i know they don't like us i
don't just i mean but every reddit board
is just like [ __ ] everybody yeah um but
i gotta give them credit that uh uh some
of the [ __ ] they post is funny i'm
guessing that uh somebody made an amazon
account or a walmart account where they
buy things and uh leave reviews
they made the name brendan schaub
oh no what did they do
and it's like uh uh
what one of the one of them was like um
[ __ ]
it was just literally a review on like
doritos or something and it was just
like and it was written as brendan but
it's all written so it's like
it literally said like talk tom about
talking about these things was fire baby
it's just like the way it's written hey
can i say this fighter the kid ready i
know you don't like us but we love you i
don't care
that's fine i get you and you probably
have many probably many valid reasons to
not like us and that's fair but we like
you still so
it's just the [ __ ] it was the way it
was written i was talking about these
things was fire b
it's just like written like the way he
talks
i wish i could pull up the whole review
but it was just i was howling laughing
at it
[ __ ] that's really good literally the
review was by brendan shaw that's really
good oh i found him all right let's just
say
i was browsing walmart for pringles when
i've seen it when i saw a special review
verified purchaser
thank him uh tombout these joints was
fire b
my boy joe rogan r.i.p told me about
them and i just had to walk them to my
trunk
great chip but great is spelt like like
steam great right great chip never met
him
brandon shop god that's so [ __ ] good
[ __ ] no people are writing c bravo by
the way bravo they're writing cte
reviews on walmart.com so if you shop on
walmart.com uh
check those reviews and look out for
brandon you can tell because the reviews
are very masculine
mexican yeah for sure talk about these
joints as far as
ah [ __ ]
so little things like that just make me
he's so easy to laugh at yeah
if he leaned into it man he'd be one of
the most likable people
but he doesn't instead he wears cut off
denim shorts like this and says then
we're supposed to not make fun of him
ah he's not wearing capris yeah he's
wearing the john cena jorts